Wow guys man how did you get I know
you've done this story before but might
I have contact Lee how we met when
tinder first emerged no yeah you guys
met on tinder yeah it was my first and
only date out of tinder what yeah and I
just want to [ __ ] run wait what well
you know I was on tinder to [ __ ] run
oh I thought you meant you wanted a
[ __ ] run from me yes I thought you
meant to hit it and split
what's the terminology so when you saw
her when you saw her you swipe I don't
even know which way you swipe right
right you swipe right look that's like
that how was the how does the DMing go
like you guys are well I have a brick to
it well he had been you know going on
several dates at this point okay I had
just gotten the app I think I met him
like my first week yeah
when I do is this I act like I don't
know how to use it oh really
yeah that's you're like getting yeah
I'll go high right and they'll go what's
up and I'll go high again and then
they're like what and I'll be it did you
say high twice yeah to make it confusing
a little bit thank you uh-huh and they
go is this working like I just doesn't
work I don't like your face right now
why that wouldn't work for you yeah yeah
I just do it in a cookie so turned off I
do it like I don't you know I do that
with life in general I think people's
game is one of the most fascinating
aspects I know of you know I mean like a
psychologist so so but then like after a
little bit of that you're intrigued do
you right away give phone number are you
like hey like you know she was
absolutely suspect of me she was yeah
yeah you know who he was
yeah but I because I knew he was I knew
that he was probably gonna pull like the
whole you know meet me at the Comedy
Store in his place of power uh-huh so I
refused that for several months she does
you have the same mom you kept saying
yeah yeah just show them so I can show
but it also Lynn I gotta tell you this
is so funny as far as like insecurities
and stuff I haven't been single in a
long time if I were single I would
definitely not invite
buddy to see me to stand up why because
I don't know that my I just feel like
yeah but you're not gonna get swipes do
you think I mean let me say something
yeah Tom Segura postman if you were like
you working for the Postal Service yeah
good job right would be great job with
great job I'm not making fun of postman
Ryan but with your face yeah right on
tinder
yeah postman postman I've gotta get a
lot of swine I think you would listen
but but I'm saying what I'm Snowden to
know what I'm saying what I'm saying is
is that did you ever throw out like a
real pig line would we ever like yeah
they're like hi and you're like once you
come over here and [ __ ] eat my gosh
at all yeah yeah you didn't know no I
the only thing that works for me is the
[ __ ] thing yeah acting rude no just
not not rout full-blown [ __ ] but
like just acting like I don't know
what's going on and he does that too
like on first dates and stuff oh really
[Music]